my 250 days a year that i work i  probably have seven to 23 days a year  where i'm like [ __ ] this i think of it  as like working out in the  360 and let's actually call it 320 days  a year that i work out i don't want to  work out 290 of them  but i know if i can just get over to  hump and get into the first five minutes  10 minutes i can get there and that's  what i think entrepreneurs need to  consider comma recently after five and a  half years six years of working out i've  been a little bit easier on myself and i  took a day and just said mike i just  don't want to go and that's been a  healthy addition i think that for  entrepreneurs even though it's all on  you as long as somebody else's  well-being  isn't being affected waking up and  saying you know i'm gonna watch cartoons  today instead is something that i don't  think people give enough permission for  that's it yeah i did one extra see ya